Traductor: Ilse S. Úziel
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Días antes de que mi padre muriera,
recuerdo mirarlo fijamente a los ojos
tenía los ojos café con
un halo grisáceo alrededor del iris;
y decirme a mí misma:
nunca olvides esos ojos.
Después de su muerte
la realidad no tenía sentido.
Tenía que entender la vida y la muerte.
Quizá por mi formación
como cine-fotógrafa,
instintivamente, así como
cuando nos da hambre,
sentí la necesidad de mirar
sus cenizas al microscopio.
Para sorpresa de todos
los científicos a los que me acerqué
que auguraron imágenes monocromáticas,
el descubrimiento que hice
transformó mi visión del mundo.
El universo entero entró en mi mente.
Era como estar flotando en el universo.
Era como ser ese espacio,
un espacio expansivo, sin cuerpo.
Era contento absoluto y se volvió paz.
Esta imagen ¿La ven?
Esa es la imagen de las cenizas
de mi padre al microscopio.
Esta otra es la del hermano
de alguien más,
y así podría enseñarles infinitas.
Todo mi miedo y toda
mi tristeza desaparecieron.
No sentí desconexión de nada ni de nadie.
Su muerte, más que un fin,
representó el principio
del que hoy es el proyecto
de mi vida: Dead Soon Project.
Para mí esto insinúa que
en nuestra más pura esencia material,
somos acariciados por el cosmos,
y que cuando nos miramos
al espejo hay quizá en ese reflejo,
infinitamente más de lo que creemos.
Que la materia no se crea ni se destruye,
se vuelve más un axioma divino,
que un principio de termodinámica.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)